Today is my husband's 40th birthday
and I wanted to surprise him with an Oreo cookie chocolate pie
since Oreos are his favourite,
so that's what I did.
Obviously I needed to fuel myself with a smoothie lunch
and use this opportunity to take my animal based prenatal vitamins.
Love that these have real ingredients from the land
like regeneratively farmed beef liver,
so I can trust I'm preparing my body for optimal fertility.
I started by making my Oreo cookie crust.
I only sweeten this cookie crust with 1/4 cup of low glycemic
coconut sugar
and then I rolled it out as thin as I could
between two sheets of Parchment paper.
While that baked,
I made some chocolate from scratch from my chocolate pie filling.
I made one bar and left the remaining 7 ounces in liquid form.
After whipping up some raw cream,
I got to making the rest of the filling.
I whisked this over a double broiler until it reached 160 degrees.
While that cooled,
I crumbled up the Oreo cookie into Oreo crumbs
to create a cookie pie crust.
I used the back of a measuring
cup to shape a huge amount of the crumbs into a pie dish
since I really love a big crust and hate when they're skimpy.
I baked the crust for 20 minutes
finished the filling by whipping my chocolate mixture with creamed
butter and then folding in the whipped cream.
The final pie came together in just A few minutes
and I finished
by shaving the homemade chocolate bar with a vegetable peeler
for the final pie decoration.
My husband was obsessed.